hello grammarians let's talk about
personal pronouns but first
let me lay some sentences on you jake
and i
baked a loaf of bread we baked a loaf of
bread
you can learn anything my friends
are cool they are cool now i'm gonna
circle a few of these words so the ones
i wrote in yellow
point them out to you i we you
my they these are personal pronouns
they're pronouns that change depending
on how you're using them
on whether you're using them as the
object of a sentence as the subject to
show ownership and so on
but we'll get to those in later videos
for now i want to talk about the three
basic types of english pronoun broadly
speaking there are pronouns about
me pronouns about you and pronouns about
something or someone
else this is an idea called grammatical
person
pronouns about me are first person
pronouns about you our second person
and pronouns about something or someone
else are third person
so when i say i love my dog friendy
i is a first person pronoun in the
sentence
she is an excellent dog where she subs
out for frying
she is a third person pronoun
here is a picture of franny i think we
can all agree she is perfect
thank you okay so what i want to do here
is fill out this table
with some of the basic pronouns we use
to talk about ourselves
divided between singular that is one
person
and plural or more than one person some
first person pronouns are i
me my and mine but what if there's more
than one of me
what if i'm part of a group and i want
to refer to that group
well then i'd use a plural pronoun like
we us
our or ours second and third person are
interesting because they have pronouns
that pull
double duty in second person the
singular
and plural are identical singular second
person
is you your and yours and plural second
person is the same
you your and yours that is to say it's
the same whether or not you're referring
to
one person here in singular or many
people here in plural
understanding whether you mean one you
or a plural you depends on context
and it's usually very easy to figure out
third person pronouns belong to the most
crowded
category because the world is full of
things and people who are neither me nor
you
for singular pronouns we have she her
and hers
he him and his they them
their and theirs and it and it's
they like you can refer to both a single
person or multiple people but it doesn't
specify a gender like she
and he do this is extremely useful take
note that the word it
only refers to inanimate objects and
sometimes non-human animals but
never to people a robot yes a person
not so much now in the plural category
much simpler we have
they them their and
similar to singular versus plural you
singular versus plural they
depends on context and it'll be obvious
from the words around it which one you
mean
this is a lot of information to swallow
pause this if you need to practice
saying the different pronouns aloud
do the exercises on the khan academy
site or app
this is not the only time i'll be
talking about personal pronouns in this
course
so we have an opportunity to go deeper
especially if you want to know more
about the history of the singular use of
they which is super cool
in the meantime please enjoy this second
image of my dog frying who is again
as i said a perfect dog you can learn
anything
dave it out